I have spent quite a while testing the
new 40 image gen from open Ai and
comparing it to models released just
yesterday for example as well as models
that aren't even publicly out yet rarely
for me in AI is one model so much better
than the rest no of course it's still
not perfect and don't even think about
showing the model a mirror because it
will frankly have a breakdown but the
word that comes to mind for me about
this new image gen and I know calling it
new is a little bit of a Str because
it's been being worked on for more than
2 years the word that comes to mind is
obedient depict six people of six
completely different ethnicities doing
jazz hands that was my prompt here okay
you could quibble that the people in the
back you can't quite see their hands but
this is not bad think of just how
recently it was that hands were such a
problem for AI this new tool which Sam
Alman is calling images in chat gbt will
be available to everyone apparently even
free users and it will also be coming to
the API so I thought it deserved its own
video featuring comparisons with reev
mid journey and I might even sneak
another model in there I'll also cover
image editing which I know is not unique
to this model you can do it with Gemini
in Google's AI Studio but still it's a
notch above the first comparison I think
is pretty Illuminating and the prompt I
used was three apples balanced on the
trunk of a blue elephant with three legs
standing beside five weeping willow
trees in elgem Tunisia obviously that is
an incredibly difficult prompt to adhere
to but I think the model did insanely
well it captured the coliseum in lgem
that I visited blue elephant you got
three apples on the trunk in every image
and kind of five trees in every image
depending on how you count it I know got
quite a few more in the background far
into the background but if you're being
generous some of these 1 2 3 4 5 pretty
accurate I'm also just noticing that the
Shadows are fairly consistent which I
think is pretty impressive but obviously
not the three legs on the elephant it's
a little bit like my Common Sense
reasoning Benchmark simple bench in that
having three legs here for an elephant
is a Twist on a common scenario and the
model just doesn't expect it and can't
really do it it's just been trained on
too many images with elephants having
the normal four legs image in 3 which is
Google's best text to image model
struggle somewhat again no three legs on
the elephant but this time the apples
are kind of wrong in number not all of
them are on the trunk and you're not
getting much of a sense of location then
of course I wanted to test reev which
was code named Half Moon previously
which is claimed by that company to be
the best image model in the world and
the way I'd phrase it is that it's very
very good if it wasn't for 40 image gen
I'd say it probably is the best image
model in the world but for now I'm going
to say second on this particular prompt
you may even prefer prer it even though
there are only four trees that I can see
but it's a really good image and great
sense of location will'll slightly more
often get the number of apples wrong but
overall despite occasional Shadow issues
the images are pretty vivid and engaging
so massive credit to reev here I'm now
going to show you a sneak peek of a
model releasing tomorrow and I think
this is a brilliant image not quite what
I was going for but nevertheless very
interesting all of the images from this
model were fairly similar engaging but
not quite what I was looking for okay
this next one you might like because I'm
sure you guys are going to see plenty of
comparisons online but I wanted to go
one meta layer higher I asked all the
models to illustrate the idiom hold your
horses that's a pretty tough test
because it's not just about visuals
literally holding a horse it's also the
idiom hold your horses slow down only
open ai's 40 image gen understood the
metaphor and in every image conveyed it
appropriately plus it gave some really
great text too of course reev as well as
having some slightly dodgy image details
just didn't really understand the
metaphor in any of the images image in
three from Google couldn't do this at
all and as you can see at the top nor
could mid Journey okay this next one's
not going to be a comparison but I think
it shows off the capabilities of 40
image gen really quite well here is one
of my classic thumbnails and I gave it
to 40 image gen and said make it 3D I
think you have to admit that with the
slight exception of anthropic logo down
here the overall results are darn
impressive I mean just for a moment
let's just focus on the fact that aside
from possibly a little line here next to
stumbles in one of the images the text
is incredibly accurate then look at this
one in the top right and I'm actually
going to zoom in the effect of the whale
coming out from the water drawn from my
thumbnail as inspiration is pretty darn
impressive now I'm not saying that I'm
going to immediately drop my traditional
thumbnail approach but for my just
released new patreon video which was
about Claude 3.7 having theory of mind
and knowing it's being tested I did want
to try it out so I got my existing
thumbnail and ran it through 40 image
gen to see what it would come up with
and as you can see you have this lab
like image with this being projected
onto the wall I don't normally like AI
thumbnails but this is probably the
first tool that has tempted me the next
test I can see being the most common use
case for image gen with chat gbt you
could call it images with captions or
basic infographics but it does really
quite well here I asked depict a four
panel Journey showing the stages of a
human life not only did I get that
Journey for each one but I got these
labels that I didn't even ask for which
I've just noticed aren't quite perfect
you can see the elderly spelled wrong
top right but again you'd be hard
pressed to say for some of these that
there's any clear mistakes now now
because I love the UI all of these tests
were done on Sora but of course we can't
forget image editing that is either
unavailable or a whole set of extra
steps with other image generators but
not so with chat gbt with images so for
one of these images I picked out and
said add glasses to each character that
got me this image where you can see the
original image is preserved just they
now have glasses all of the other image
generators had problems with the four
stages of Life although reev came the
closest with this image I mean it kind
of Skips out everything from the age of
21 to 81 but not bad mid Journey went
super metaphorical and artistic but I
did say human life and I can't really
see humans here the unreleased model
went in a completely different direction
which I kind of like but I'm a bit
confused by now I did miss my
opportunity to talk about Native image
generation and editing in Google AI
studio with Gemini 2 flash but now I
have got a chance the comparison isn't
quite as favorable I said depict a four
panel Journey again showing the stages
of a human life and got this and it
makes me wonder before I was born was I
a robo dog with a stick in my back
quarter anyway we can edit the images
and I said change the baby on the right
to being an old man and as you can see I
got this okay now for some disclaimers
and a few times I was denied permission
for an image so there are filters for
the new image gen it did allow me to
submit a photo of the Google CEO and Sam
Orman the CEO of open Ai and I said make
these two people arm wrestle and even
though the Fidelity to how they look
isn't perfect this image in the top left
isn't bad and I thought I would be
denied this generation but I wasn't you
can let me know in the comments whether
you think slightly less filtering is a
good thing but for me true safety is
about things like bioweapons and cyber
weapons that's why you through my new
Link in the description can and possibly
should enter the grace one Arena if you
have any interest or aptitude in
jailbreaking models testing whether they
can do these kind of things and yes
appropriately that now includes visual
vulnerabilities breaking models through
the images you submit to them or you're
just interested in big prize pools do
check out the link in the description
and yes as you may have noticed the
prize pools are getting a bit out of
control in case you're wondering because
I'm doing this in Sora I can turn any
image into a video but honestly I
wouldn't quite recommend it even when
you're using storyboards the results
aren't exactly
lifelike the six different people with
different ethnicities doing jazz hands
was probably one of the most impressive
outputs I saw from image gen mainly for
the reason that that was a stark
weakness of image gen models going back
last year and the year before and also
just that it was so much better than
other models at this particular prompt
mid Journey struggled hard Google's
imageen 3 denied me entir L and Reeve
wasn't bad we do have the six different
people I wouldn't exactly call this jazz
hands though one thing I do have to
mention of course is that when you're
using chat GPT to generate images it is
going to be slower typically than the
other models but here was another test
that I hope you guys like just so you
can see it I said create a difficult
what we call in Britain where's Wally or
where Waldo style image with an italic
caption telling the viewer what to look
for it should take at least 10 seconds
to solve now I'm going to scroll through
the images and you can of course pause
the video but the generations while
artistically very interesting but for me
all suffered from the same problem which
is that they didn't actually display the
thing that they told you to look for
unless you want to be very generous and
count this thing here as a tiger but
that is a big stretch you know what in
this one I'm actually going to give it
to imagin 3 because I can see that it's
saying find the time traveler in the
medieval Marketplace and even though the
text is kind of screwed up and it's very
easy to spot at least it's there and
it's kind of cool Reeve created very
beautiful images but again I think they
suffered from that same problem of not
actually having the thing that you're
supposed to look for honestly don't
waste too much of your time but if you
do see them let me know I'm going to
give reev a pass on this image because
they said find the pirate hiding among
the beach goers and I'm going to say
this is the pirate not really hiding but
there we go I guess this serves to
illustrate the point which is the logic
the kind of brains of 40 image gen is
just noticeably better than the others
the the artisticness is probably similar
obviously most people will just use this
to turn their selfies into charcoal
sketches or Dragon Ball Z characters
that's pretty obvious but the fact that
we now have ai models capable of
producing an image like this one with
just incredibly accurate text and
genuine logic behind what it's
portraying that is a true moment in AI
it's worth a dedicated video because
sometimes incremental change can add up
to big change so is this a storm in a
teacup or a true moment in AI will you
never use this tool or use it hundreds
of times like I'm expecting to let me
know thank you so much for watching see
you in the next video which should be
coming very soon and have a wonderful
day